[Musica]
spesso le storie più belle iniziano da
un sogno il mio di sogno è sempre stato
quello di diventare una scienziata con
la s maiuscola l'avventura che vi voglio
raccontare è il percorso che mi ha
portato a realizzare questo sogno Oggi
sono una ricercatrice di ruolo al CNR il
mio percorso è legato allo studio
dell'are solo atmosferico e non posso
non parlarvi di questo argomento per due
motivi sia la rilevanza scientifica gli
addetti ai lavori parlano di micro
oggetti con un macro impatto sul nostro
pianeta sia perché è un argomento che mi
sta proprio a cuore direi che l'ho
vissuto in prima persona Infatti più mi
sono addentrata nello studio delle leggi
che governano l'areosol più mi sono resa
conto che si applicano anche a noi
esseri umani e per questo voglio
parlarvi di tre aspetti dell' areosol
quelli che più si sono intrecciati col
mio vissuto quindi Lasciando da parte
formule e tecnicismi vi parlerò della
Bellezza degli aerosol atmosferici e se
mi mi seguirete con gli occhi
dell'immaginazione vi porterò lontano ma
partiamo dall'inizio dalla definizione
Che cos'è un areosol Beh semplice lo
dice la parola stessa che è formata da
Aero cioè aria e Sol l'iniziale di
solution che sta per sospensione sono
oggetti in sospensione nell'aria anche
qui attorno a noi anche se non li
vediamo una miriade di sostanze diverse
dipendono dalla sorgente che li ha
generati possono essere frammenti di
organismi biologici ceneri da eruzioni
vulcaniche o da processi di combustione
inquinanti generati dalle attività
antropiche o ancora polveri una miriade
di polveri dall'erosione delle montagne
dalla risospensione del suolo polveri
dal trasporto di
ehm di polveri del deserto Insomma una
miriade di sostanze che sono in
sospensione nell'aria ma non
immaginatevi ferme sono continuamente
trasportate dalle masse d'aria alcuni
precipitano poco distante dalla sorgente
si parla di sedimentazione
gravitazionale e hanno un viaggio molto
corto altre quelle che mi interessano di
più Invece effettuano un viaggio molto
più lungo e questo è il primo aspetto di
cui vi voglio parlare il primo aspetto è
che gli aeros solo atmosferici possono
viaggiare a lungo quanto Beh possono
viaggiare per giorni anche settimane
percorrendo centinaia di chilometri per
farvi un esempio concreto qui anche qui
alle nostre latitudini riceviamo
l'influenza di areo Sol trasportato dal
deserto del Sahara Ricordatevi la parola
deserto perché ritornerà comunque una
distanza strabiglia
vuol dire che particelle microscopiche
hanno viaggiato Oltrepassando Mari
montagne e per un viaggio così lungo per
riuscirci hanno dovuto superare molti
ostacoli anche solo le goccioline di
pioggia e come fa un areosol a superare
tutti questi ostacoli a viaggiare così a
lungo ha un solo modo adattarsi ai
Bruschi cambi di direzione delle delle
masse d'aria che lo trasportano quindi
l'aria solo che non ce la fa spesso È
l'areosol troppo inerte che continua su
una traiettoria rettilinea prestabilita
e finisce per impattare l'ostacolo
invece l'areosol che viaggia lungo è
quello che riesce a adattarsi al
cambiamento adattarsi al cambiamento una
massima che in realtà è forte anche per
noi esseri umani e quando io l'ho resa
mia Beh c'è stata una vera e propria
chiave di svolta nella mia vita il
quando iniziato ad avere un approccio
meno rigido alla vita a adattarmi di più
ai Bruschi cambi di direzione e della
vita a salire sulle possibilità che mi
si presentavano ho iniziato a crescere
umanamente professionalmente ho lavorato
ai quattro angoli del pianeta in Francia
in Inghilterra Addirittura in Giappone e
ogni nuovo posto ogni nuova persona che
incontravo mi contamin permettendomi di
evolvere e immaginate un po' è così
anche per l'areosol l'areosol che
viaggia lungo può entrare in contatto
con altri gas con altre particelle
nell'atmosfera
e sarà contaminato da questo mescolo di
altre sostanze anche proprio in termini
scientifici si parla di Stato di
mescolamento o di invecchiamento E
questa evoluzione dell' areosol lungo il
viaggio può andare a modificarne le
proprietà e parlo in particolare di una
proprietà che è il secondo aspetto di
cui vi voglio parlare l'aerosol può
influenzare le
nuvole Eh sì le nuvole che vediamo nel
cielo sono fatte anche di Aerosol Cioè
l'areosol è proprio un edente
fondamentale per le nuvole fornisce
infatti una superficie sopra cui il
vapore acquo può condensare formando le
goccioline di nube ma in nube non ci
sono solo le goccioline ci sono anche
dei cristalli di ghiaccio e quando c'è
l'areosol la formazione del ghiaccio può
avvenire più facilmente Ma guardate solo
una categoria rara di Aerosol può
aiutare a creare i cristalli di ghiaccio
si parla a circa di Uno su un milione è
una categoria rara l'unica ad avere
un'affinità elettiva con l'acqua
questo processo seppure raro di
formazione del ghiaccio in nube quando
avviene in realtà ha un effetto a
cascata da pochi cristalli isolati il
ghiaccio si moltiplica fino a portare
alla precipitazione e quando penso a
questa idea un Aro Sol Sum milione che
ce la fa trasformarsi in cristallo di
ghiaccio e poi si moltiplica cambiando
tutto tutto l'ambiente circostante Beh
non posso non pensare alla storia delle
donne nella scienza da pochi casi
isolati ci siamo moltiplicate e ogni
nuova donna che ce fa nel percorso
scientifico incoraggia le altre a
farcela e per questo io sono qui oggi
per incoraggiare tutte le altre donne
presenti in sala verso percorsi
scientifici donne e ragazze perché non
siamo ancora abbastanza nei percorsi
scientifici ma torniamo a parlare di
areosol l'areosol che influenza le
nuvole vi dicevo quello più influente
riesce a creare cristalli di ghiaccio si
parla di
nucleatum Ma chi sarà mai questa areosol
Beh Pensate un po' l'areosol del deserto
possiede questa affinità elettiva e
riesce a nucleare il ghiaccio io me lo
immagino come un quadro in aria deserto
e aria e acqua si ritrovano e come due
innamorati si attraggono e formano un
oggetto bellissimo e Perfetto un
cristallo di ghiaccio che precipita il
suolo e se precipitando incontra un
ghiacciaio Beh il viaggio sarà stato
veramente strabiglia
la memoria di questo viaggio scritto per
centinaia di anni e questo è il terzo
aspetto di cui voglio parlare ci sono
areosol intrappolati nei ghiacciai che
portano informazioni importanti sul
passato del nostro pianeta Ma ve lo
ripeto i ghiacciai Soprattutto quelli
dell'Antartide sono una biblioteca delle
atmosfere passate del nostro pianeta e
per decifrare questa biblioteca Gli
scienziati usano fra gli altro gli
aerosol intrappolati nelle carote di
ghiaccio questo io lo so bene perché ho
passato 13 mesi e sopra un ghiacciaio
per inseguire queste ricerche ho preso
parte alla 18A campagna invernale del
pnra il pnra è il programma italiano di
ricerca in Antartide è un programma
finanziato dal Miur che riceve il
supporto logistico da Inea e supporto
scientifico dal CNR è il programma che
mi ha permesso di vivere per vivere 13
mesi sopra un ghiacciaio e in Antartide
ho trovato un luogo unico in cui però
immaginate un po' c'è l'assenza di acqua
allo stato liquido quello che manca di
più è è la pioggia i fiumi l'aria stessa
è secca e per tutti questi motivi si
parla di un deserto di ghiaccio un
deserto di ghiaccio che però riceve
l'influenza di polveri desertiche dal
Sud America e dall'Australia E qui la
mia storia volge al termine vi ho
parlato di un deserto di ghiaccio che è
connesso a un deserto di sabbia e
polvere passando per le nuvole ed è
questo che fa la areosol Crea fili
invisibili in ogni compartimento del
nostro pianeta e vi ho parlato del
viaggio dell' areosol è un viaggio lungo
che lo porta addirittura a interagire
con le nuvole a trasformarsi in
cristallo di ghiaccio e da ghiaccio può
moltiplicarsi e precipitare Fino sopra
un ghiacciaio va avver potuto parlarvi
di altri tipi di Aerosol Non solo
dell'aerosol desertico anche dello spray
Marino degli inquinanti In effetti
l'areosol a tutti gli effetti crea delle
trame che con le nostre stesse azioni al
resto del pianeta e gli scienziati
tentano di decifrare queste trame E con
questo scopo ogni anno un gruppo scelto
di Scienziati va in Antartide tentando
di decifrare il passato del nostro
pianeta per avere chiavi per il
futuro ed ecco vorrei finire qui
parlandovi Per un'ultima volta di quello
che io ho imparato dagli arol
studiandone le sue proprietà Beo ha
imparato soprattutto a fluire fluire
davanti al cambiamento in inglese si
dice go with the flow e poi preso la
consapevolezza che tutto è connesso
anche quando non è tangibile e con
questa consapevolezza Ho provato a
conciliare il mio essere madre con la
mia passione
scientifica perché l'amore di una mamma
è come un filo invisibile che non si
cancella né con la
distanza né nello spazio né nel tempo
come potete immaginare la sfida più
grande per me è stata quella di passare
13 mesi lontana da mio figlio come ho
fatto beh ho tentato di nutrire questo
legame invisibile che mi connetteva con
mio figlio tentando sempre di farlo
sentire complice Nonostante la
distanza e so di avercela fatta perché
quando sono tornata dopo 13 mesi di
distanza negli occhi di mio figlio non
ho visto rancore ma
orgoglio
Grazie